[Musique]
pourquoi tu veux tu faire ça
regarde-moi n'écoute que ma voix je ne
te laisserai pas jean
on est une famille budget quoi qu'il
arrive
regarde
tu es nikitine
[Musique]
si tu cesses de lutter contre la force
qui l'habitent
l'afld etienne
tu disposera du pouvoir d'un dieu
elle va tous nous tuer dites-moi ce
qu'on peut faire charles dites moi quoi
faire c'est pas possible
ceux qui ne comprennent pas
ils le craignent est ce qu'ils craignent
ils cherchent à le détruire
c'est votre faute charles
je voulais la protéger
j'ai peur de sable
quand je ne contrôle plus il arrive
malheur je refusais il faut la détruire
c'est toujours jean on peut quand même
l'aider
on voudrait parfois que les gens soient
ceux qu'ils ne sont pas
et quand on comprend enfin qu'ils sont
il est trop tard
elle arrive